If you’ve watched my review of Ex Machina,
you’ll know what a big fan I am of this
superlative sci-fi film starring Alicia Vikander,
Oscar Isaac and Domhnall Gleeson.
Let’s take a look at 5 things you probably
didn’t know about Ex Machina!
One of the biggest challenges of Ex Machina
was designing the film’s android, Ava, so
that she didn’t just look like the robots
we’ve seen on screen before.
Writer and director Alex Garland worked on
the design with British comic book artist
Jock, who he’d previously worked with on
the sci-fi action movie Dredd.
The breakthrough in making Ava’s design
feel fresh was covering her form in mesh,
which means we can see straight through her
to her skeleton structure and inner workings.
However, in certain lighting conditions, the
mesh catches the light and so her body takes
on a more human form.
It took 6 weeks to film Ex Machina, but the
post-production process took 6 months.
The visual effects team spent hours matching
their animation to the movements of actress
Alicia Vikander, who plays Ava, and they translated
as much as possible of Vikander’s on-set
performance into their CG model.
And as visual effects supervisor Andrew Whitehurst
wanted his team to approach Ava’s design
with fresh eyes, he banned them from looking
at pictures of robots!
Instead, they took inspiration from sculptures
by Brâncuși, modernist Bauhaus sculptures,
Formula One suspension, and high-end concept
bicycles!
And, to make sure they got Ava’s movements
right, they also researched human anatomy.
Ex Machina is set in Alaska at the home-come-research
facility of Nathan, the billionaire genius
who created Ava.
But what appears in the movie to be one location
in Alaska, in reality is two different locations
in Norway!
Many of the interior and exterior shots in
Ex Machina are from a private residence and
the Juvet Landscape Hotel, both of which are
located in the Norwegian Fjords outside a
town called Valldal.
Both the house and hotel were designed by
Norwegian architects Jensen & Skodvin.
When combined, the two buildings’ features,
including glass walls and spectacular views
over the Norwegian wilderness, gave Ex Machina’s
filmmakers a place that looked like the kind
of beautiful, private world in which the super-rich
would live.
Filming also took place at Pinewood Studios
in the UK.
A number of interior sets, including Ava’s
observation room, were built at Pinewood to
match the design features of the Norwegian
locations, and blue-screen was used to add
in the landscape through the windows.
If you’ve read Alex Garland’s novel The
Beach, you’ll know that he’s a fan of
Francis Ford Coppola’s critically acclaimed
war movie Apocalypse Now.
And Garland sees definite similarities between
Ex Machina’s reclusive billionaire boss
Nathan, played by Oscar Isaac, and Apocalypse
Now’s rogue US Army Special Forces operative,
Colonel Walter E. Kurtz, played by Marlon
Brando.
For instance, like Kurtz, Nathan has isolated
himself geographically and psychologically.
For Nathan this has meant holing himself up
in his super-remote location to work on his
latest project.
and like Kurtz, Nathan sees himself as a sort
of god.
Plus, as Garland’s said, Nathan’s “spent
too much time up the river and has gone a
bit crazy.
At the point we meet him, he’s already tipped
over the edge.”
Both Alicia Vikander, who stars as Ava, and
Sonoya Mizuno, who plays Nathan’s mysterious
silent assistant Kyoko, have backgrounds in
ballet.
Vikander attended the Royal Swedish Ballet
School for nine years until she landed a part
in a Swedish TV series in her mid-teens.
And Mizuno trained with the Royal Ballet School
in London before going on to join the National
Ballet of Ireland and Scottish Ballet.
According to director Alex Garland, the many
years both actresses spent training as ballerinas
was invaluable to their performances in Ex
Machina as it meant they had such discipline
and control of their bodies that they could
express a great deal about their characters
with just slight movements.
Well, there you have it, 5 things you probably
didn't know about Ex Machina!
Now, tell me, who’s your favourite robot
character in the movies?
If you enjoyed this video, hit the thumbs-up
button and subscribe for more things you didn't
know and weekly movie reviews and interviews.
Thanks for watching!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!